[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute mit barbara
guten abend und willkommen ihnen allen
an meiner seite ist für den sport rudi
cerne hallo gotland und das sind die
nachrichten themen von heute
annäherung bei rüstungsausgaben
ampelkoalition und union verhandeln
erneut über 100 milliarden euro für die
bundeswehr
konfrontation auf dem tempelberg in
jerusalem tag kommt es zu
ausschreitungen zwischen palästinensern
und der israelischen polizei
und königlicher triumph in paris real
madrid feiert den 14
champions-league-sieg die uefa
untersucht das einlass chaos vor
spielbeginn
als reaktion auf den russischen
einmarsch in der ukraine hatte der
bundeskanzler im februar angekündigt die
bundeswehr massiv aufzurüsten mit 100
milliarden euro über die details wird
noch gestritten doch scholz hofft dass
die verhandlungsrunde mit der union
heute abend zur einigung führt aus
berlin karl hilton hinterleitner
es gibt streit um das sogenannte
sondervermögen klar ist 100 milliarden
sollen es sein aber wie und wohin genau
fließt das geld die union will alles
ausschließlich für die bundeswehr die
grünen wollen auch mittel in die abwehr
von digitalen angriffen stecken
sicherheit ist mehr als alleine
investitionen in die bundeswehr wir sind
zum beispiel auch sehr anfällig gegen
cyberangriffe und diese spielen eine
rolle wie nie zuvor und deswegen sagen
wir und sagt die bundesregierung
gemeinsam das auch dafür das geld
ausgegeben werden sollte wie genau das
nato ziel zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für die
verteidigung auf zuwendet verankert wird
ist noch unklar für die geplante
grundgesetzänderung ist eine
zweidrittelmehrheit nötig also die
zustimmung der union doch die hat klare
bedingungen
nach unserer meinung müssen die mittel
wirklich zu 100 prozent bei der
bundeswehr landen das ist ganz ganz
wichtig denn da ist wirklich der
nachholbedarf und diese 100 milliarden
dürfen jetzt nicht gewissermaßen der
bedientheke werden für alle wünsche und
dinge die die ampel sonst noch so vorhat
die fdp ist bei der genauen verwendung
der 100 milliarden verhandlungsbereit
und für die heutigen gespräche
optimistisch es ist vollkommen klar dass
die bundeswehr das allermeiste geld
bekommen soll und die frage gibt es
vielleicht noch andere dinge die der
verteidigungsfähigkeit dienen die
wichtig sind für die sicherheit unseres
landes darüber muss verhandelt werden da
sind wir aber nicht so weit auseinander
deswegen würde ich auch nicht verstehen
wenn wir an diesem punkt heute keine
lösung finden werden in diesen minuten
kommen die gesprächspartner im
finanzministerium zusammen es könnte ein
langer abend werden
ein gespräch mit der spd vorsitzenden
saskia esken zum thema sehen sie direkt
nach uns in berlin direkt
der ukrainische präsident seelands
gefordert dass rund russland endlich
offiziell als terrorstaat eingestuft
wird er will das morgen beim
eu-sondergipfel zur ukraine ansprechen
vor wenigen stunden besuchte selensky
erstmals seit kriegsbeginn die umkämpfte
region harke dort machte er sich ein
bild von der zerstörung und dankte den
ukrainischen soldatinnen und soldaten
schweden und finnland wollen ja mitglied
der nato werden nur die türkei stellt
sich quer der türkische präsident
erdogan bekräftigte heute noch mal so
lange er an der spitze des staates stehe
werde die türkei nicht ja sagen zu einem
nato-beitritt von ländern die den terror
unterstützen
nach jerusalem die palästinenser
empfinden es jedes jahr als provokation
wenn zum flaggen marsch israelis durch
muslimische viertel der stadt ziehen um
an die eroberung ostjerusalems während
des sechstagekrieges zu erinnern
tausende waren es heute flankiert von
sicherheitskräften schon im vorfeld kam
es zu zusammenstößen michael b warum
der flaggen marsch durch das damaskus
tor und das muslimische viertel zur
klagemauer für nationale israelis ist es
die demonstration des triumphes von 1967
als ost-jerusalem erobert wurde das ist
inzwischen annektiert ganz jerusalem die
hauptstadt von israel von den meisten
staaten allerdings nicht anerkannt
ich bin nach jerusalem gekommen um unser
volk unser land und unsere fahne zu
unterstützen wir marschieren hier nicht
um zu provozieren sondern weil jerusalem
ein teil vom volk israel ist vom land
israel
das sehen die palästinenser anders nicht
nur der flaggen marsch ist für sie reine
provokation auch der besuch von
ultranationalisten wie dem abgeordneten
band wird auf dem tempelberg der besuch
dort ist juden erlaubt aber ohne gebiet
oder politische bekundung nach
ausschreitungen am morgen geraten juden
und muslime auch in der altstadt zum
teil heftig aneinander
die polizei lässt diese wahnsinnigen
hierher sie kommen schlagen uns mich hat
man geschlagen dann habe ich das
geschäft geschlossen und sie haben
meinen laden beschädigt
die da haben auf uns geschmeckt dabei
haben wir gar nichts gemacht diese stadt
gehört ihnen nicht das ist unsere stadt
und unser land
immer wieder eskaliert die situation und
die hamas droht mit gewaltsamen aktionen
bis hin zu raketenangriffen viele hatten
vor diesem fladen marsch gewarnt der die
fronten nur verhärtet hat
in nordrhein westfalen stehen die
zeichen auf schwarz grün die
spitzengremien von cdu und grünen haben
am abend beschlossen
koalitionsverhandlungen aufzunehmen
beide parteien hatten sich in
sondierungsgesprächen bereits auf
konkrete ziele verständigt was kino kann
das hat wieder mal das filmfestival in
cannes bewiesen zum abschluss wurden
gestern abend die palmen an die besten
vergeben die wichtigste ging schon zum
zweiten mal an den schwedischen
regisseur ruben östlund der direkt das
publikum in seine freude integrierte
anne arendt hat
[Musik]
anarchie in cannes für seine bitterböse
satire gewinnt der schwede ruben östlund
die goldene palme
der film beginnt in der welt zwei models
ein mann und eine frau spielt dann auf
einer luxusjacht und endet auf einer
einsamen insel in der hierarchie nicht
mehr gelten es geht darum wie sich das
verhalten verändert
der titel trial of sadness beschreibt
die sorgenfalte zwischen den augen die
bei models nicht erwünscht ist die welt
der super schönen und superreichen wird
den grellen karikaturen zur schau
gestellt mit iris berben in einer
nebenrolle
nachdenklich stimmt auch der film der
iranerin sahra mirebrahimi nach einer
verleumdungskampagne war sie aus ihrer
heimat geflohen in cannes wird sie nun
als beste schauspielerin geehrt
[Applaus]
das bedeutet mir sehr viel und ich denke
an all die frauen im iran die mich jetzt
sehen es gibt ihnen hoffnung macht ihnen
mut
den preis als bester männlicher
darsteller erhält der südkoreaner song
kang ho zwölf tage internationale kino
kunst in cannes mit einer vielfalt an
filmen feierte das festival seine 75 der
jubiläumsausgabe an der côte d'azur
in paris beim champions-league-finale
man nicht alles zum feiern auf keinen
fall 105 festnahmen 238 verletzte das
ist die traurige bilanz nach dem finale
der fußball champions league in paris
real madrid gewannen durch das 1 0 gegen
liverpool zum vierzehnten mal den
wettbewerb der königsklasse der triumph
wurde allerdings überschattet durch die
chaotischen vorkommnisse vor dem spiel
ist vor dem spiel an den eingängen des
stade de france fans versuchen über den
zaun ins stadion zu kommen andere wütend
dahinter wallaus sind trotz tickets
offenbar nicht rechtzeitig reingelassen
werden es ist absolut chaotisch die
franzosen ihre organisation und die uefa
einfach schrecklich die uefa vermutet
die verbreitung gefälschter tickets sei
auslöser für die massiven einlass
probleme gewesen auch der französische
innenminister macht auf twitter die
britischen fans ohne tickets für das
chaos verantwortlich und bedankte sich
bei den sicherheitskräften
die greifen hart durch aber laut aussage
begleitender englische polizisten läge
die schuld nicht bei den fans von der
insel erst mit 36 minuten verspätung
wird angegriffen liverpool über weite
strecken überlegen kann aber courtois
den überragenden torwart der madrilenen
nicht überwinden anders real der einzige
treffer des spiels durch vinicius junior
real madrid wird zum vierzehnten mal
champions-league-sieger feierstimmung
auch heute in madrid aber genauso in
liverpool
der mexikaner sergio perez hat das
formel 1 rennen um den großen preis von
monaco gewonnen der start auf dem
stadtkurs wegen starken regens fast eine
stunde verspätet hinter dem safety-car
dann schrecksekunde für mit schumacher
der diesen unfall aber offenbar
unversehrt übersteht die schlussphase
dann im trockenen peres gewinn von
carlos sainz und max verstappen der die
wm wertung weiterhin anführt und
alexander zverev hat bei den french open
in paris das viertelfinale erreicht
gegen den ungesetzten spanier bernabe
admirals setzte sich der hamburger
weltranglisten-dritte in drei sätzen 7 6
7 5 und 6 3 durch der runde der letzten
acht wird zverev nun entweder auf den
russen karin katalog oder auf carlos
alcaraz aus spanien treffen
und das war der sport mit schönen glen
zungenbrecher nur dankeschön fehlt noch
der blick aufs wetter da wechseln sonne
und wolken an den alpen und im nordosten
gibt es schauer und kurze gewitter
zwischen main und donau ist es länger
sonnig die temperatur erreicht 13 bis 21
grad ab dienstag wird es jeden tag ein
bisschen wärmer es bleibt aber leicht
unbeständig das heute journal mit
marietta slomka um viertel vor zehn wir
sagen tschüss wünschen ihnen einen guten
start in die neue woche und empfehlen
jetzt berlin direkt mit chuck und aller
welt vielen dank barbara